- [Instructor] Derrick
is a political pollster
tracking the approval rating
of the prime minster in his country.
At the end of each month, he obtains data
from a random sample of adults
on whether or not they currently approve
of the prime minister's performance,
using a separate sample each month.
Derrick wants to test if the proportion
of adults who approved
was significantly lower
in December than it was in November.
Which of the following
is an appropriate set
of hypotheses for Derrick's
significance test?
Pause this video and
see if you can figure it
out on your own.
Alright, so let's think about ways
to write a null hypothesis first.
So, remember, your null
hypothesis is assuming
that there's no news here.
There's no difference.
So, one way to say it is
that the true proportion
in December is equal to your
true proportion in November.
Another way to write
that exact same thing is
to say that your, the difference
between the true proportion in December,
and let's see.
They say, Derrick wants
to test if the proportion
of adults who approved
was significantly lower
in December than it was in November.
And so, you could write it as
because he's wanting to
see if November is higher
or not, I'll put November first.
So, another way to say
this exact same thing is
that the true proportion of November
minus the true proportion in
December is equal to zero.
So, each of these would look,
be legitimate null hypotheses
and so, let's see,
this one looks good.
This one looks good.
This one is not a
legitimate null hypothesis
for what we're trying to do.
So, we could rule out D.
And then, the other one it says,
Derrick wants to test if the proportion
of adults who approved
was significantly lower
in December than it was in November.
So, the news here would be if this is,
if this actually is the case.
If we have evidence that the true propor,
that the proportion of adults who approved
was significantly lower in
December than it was in November.
So, that the alternative hypothesis
could look something like this.
That the proportion in December was less
than the proportion in November.
Or, it could be that the proportion
in November is greater than
the proportion in December.
And, if we look at these choices,
the proportion in December is less
than the proportion in November.
That's what I wrote right over here.
So, that looks good as well.
Here, they swap it.
Here, they're saying our
alternative hypothesis is
that the true proportion
December is larger,
is more than the true
proportion in November
which is the opposite of what say here.
So, we rule that one out.
Here, they're just saying that
we actually have a difference
in the proportions.
And, many times, you will
see something like this,
but here, Derrick wants
to test if the proportion
of adults who approved
was significantly lower
in December than in November.
He's not interested in
the other way around.
If he said, if it said
Derrick wants to test
if the proportion of adults
who approved was significantly different
in December than November,
then you would pick choice
C instead of choice A.
But, given the way it was phrased,
I would pick choice A.
Let's do another example.
Here, it says that Kiley
has a dime and a nickel
and she wonders if they
have the same likelihood
of showing heads when they are flipped.
She flips each coin 100 times to test
if there is a significant difference
in the proportion of flips
that they each land showing heads.
Which of the following
is an appropriate set
of hypotheses for Kiley's
significance test?
So, once again, pause the video.
Try to do it on your own.
Alright, well, your
null hypothesis would be
that there is no difference.
So, that the proportion of getting heads
with your dime is the
same as your proportion
of heads with your nickel.
And then, your alternative hypothesis,
so it says here she fl,
she wants to test if there's
a significant difference.
She's not trying to say if the proportion
of dimes coming up head
is significantly lower
or significantly larger.
She just cares about the difference.
If there's a significant difference
in the proportion of slips.
So, her alternative hypothesis is
that there is a difference.
That these two proportions
are not equal to each other.
And, so, if we look at the choices,
so this null hypothesis looks good.
This null hypothesis does not look good.
Remember, you're null hypothesis,
you're trying to assume that,
man, there's no news here.
So, all of these null hypotheses,
these, A, B, and D's null
hypotheses look good.
And then, the alternative hypotheses is
this is exactly what we
wrote before is for choice D.
Choice A's alternative
hypothesis would work
if here it said she
flips each coin 100 times
to test if there is, if the proportion
of heads with the dime
is significantly lower
than the proportion of
heads with the nickel
or something like that.
And then, if it was the reverse,
then choice B would look good.
But, she just wants to see
if there's a difference,
not if one is lower than the other.
And, so I would pick choice D.